un autre sujet qui n'a vraiment rien à
voir on a appris aujourd'hui que le prix
moyen du mètre carré à paris avait
dépassé les dix mille euros c'est une
hausse de plus de 60% en disant tout ça
peut être à crédit qu une des thèses des
manuels macro qui consiste à dire que
les propriétaires immobiliers sont un
peu des rentiers en particulier quand
ils ont un gros patrimoine et que doc il
est normal de les taxer lourdement ce
sujet avait fait l'objet d'un figaro
magazine de ce week-end c'est une
publicité gratuite puisque le magazine
n'est plus en vente mais il l'est nous a
valu beaucoup de réactions sur internet
de propriétaires qui considère injuste
d'être taxé de la sorte à la fois sur le
capital avec l'ifi et aussi dans leurs
revenus fonciers
l'expression prétentieuse pour dire
loyers en tout cas emmanuel macron lui
il assume il n'a pas changé de cap il le
disait quand ils étaient seulement
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
c'était en février 2010 est sur france
inter je transforme lisf en impôts sur
la rente immobilière dans notre pays il
y à une rente immobilière qui doit être
taxé elle n'est pas productive quand
vous avez et je maintiens l'abattement
sur la résidence principale et d'aucune
compris les l'agricole et l arrivée et
compte y compris et l'impôt sur les
biens les résidences secondaires et
c'est parce que ça c'est un élément de
rendre ça ne finance pas mon économie
voilà on vous pose la question sur
twitter selon vous les propriétaires
sont ils trop taxés et 83 % répondent
oui il est 17 % doivent être des
locataires probablement cessé bertrand
perrier se conceptuellement l'idée de
dire bah c'est normal de beaucoup taxer
les propriétaires parce que il crée pas
de richesse parce que ça se comprend
mais c'est assez étonnant
qu'est ce qui crée le plus de richesses
à château qu'on fait entretenir avec
lequel on n'a des corps de métiers qui
interviennent parce que ça fait partie
du patrimoine
si vous saviez qu'un challenge était que
vous avez pas trois pièces dans le 11e
et je suis dans les 13 % donc du sondage
est évidemment non mais et où vous est
ce que finalement et donc doit être
absolument taxer tcc de fortune
immobilière ou est ce que rapporte
davantage des mouvements financiers
transfrontaliers
c'est assez les étonnant de voir qu'on a
réservé la taxation au à l'immobilier en
que soient partagées non mais je suis
pas ta pub à partager je trouve que il
est injuste de postuler par principe que
la fortune immobilière serait une
fortune dormantes et qui ne produirait
pas de l'économie réelle alors que les
flux financiers eux devraient être
exonérées de taxation
gérard jaffrès est votre avis aussi
écouter ce qui est frappant dans cette
affaire malgré tout c'est les messages
et messages récemment des ministres
pendant le grand débat les ministres ont
donné leurs idées mais alors quelle idée
faut voir augmentation d'impôt par ci
par là alors bruno le maire qu'on avait
connu mieux inspiré je dois dire à part
les mêmes de la taxation des plus values
sur la vente de la résidence principale
à sa voix là une idée pour reconstituer
l'électorat de droite et permettra la
liste des républicains de faire un bon
score le 26 mai à voilà une idée
bruno le maire est donc peut donc
apparaître comme une sorte d' agent
dormant de la droite installée dans la
ma chronique parce que là je dois dire
que c'est assez fort faut bien voir que
le pouvoir macro nice s'est attaqué à
trois éléments fondamentaux
il s'est attaqué aux catégories
populaires à travers la voiture de la
taxe carbone et ça ça fait du monde il
s'est attaqué aux personnes âgées à
travers les retraites
deuxième élément emma et menaces
s'attaquer aux propriétaires il l'a fait
à travers l'ifi le fait de maintenir un
impôt sur la fortune immobilière alors
qu'on aurait pu imaginer qu'il
maintiendrait un isf en baissant ses
taux premièrement qui était beaucoup
trop élevé par rapport à ce que rapporte
l'argent à notre époque et deuxièmement
en i en demandant aussi qu'ils puissent
est fléché vers l'économie et des
investissements économiques en totalité
alors que cette est plafonnée bref il y
avait d'autres façons de faire mais du
coup je me dis que les messages que
reçoivent alors d'une part ceux qui
dépendent de la voiture pour vivre tous
les jours ceux qui dépendent de leur
retraite et qui n'a aucun autre moyen
pour vivre et ceux qui sont
propriétaires de leurs biens 58% des
français sont propriétaires de leurs
biens
tous ces messages font bas vous
aboutissez à 70% des français
aujourd'hui mécontents de mâcon et mac
web populaires auprès de 70% du pays
parce que ce sont des messages qui
infuse et en même temps elle se fit le
tac c'est vrai que si on est
propriétaire à paris son patrimoine a
augmenté de 60 % en dix ans sans qu'on
n'ait rien fait il ya une forme
d'injustice là-dedans paris et
particuliers en fait c'est vrai c'est la
différence à luçon et déjà ses leçons
qu'on n'ait rien fait des travaux voilà
je crois qu'elle ait beaucoup de travaux
il ya un mélange de deux un mélange de
deux idées en ville il ya une idée qui
est pertinente qui était donc qui sont
tombés dans la campagne de magnanac
rookie est effectivement de dire qu' il
faudrait peut-être dégager enfin fait
râler les investissements verts vers le
productive a les idées ce qu'on appelle
les ide plutôt que la rente immobilière
qui est clairement une rente sur le plan
économique
bon ça c'est une idée qui peut se
défendre et notamment en france où il ya
un gros problème qui est un autre
problème qui est problème de la mobilité
qui est rendue très difficile par le
fait que comme les droits
il est frais de notaire sont très élevés
quand on s'achète un pavillon par
exemple un même dans une petite commune
on paye des droits tellement important
que c'est difficile de déménager donc
c'est un vrai problème l'immobilier
aujourd'hui il estime enfin il
immobilise bon donc il y avait une idée
qui était plutôt pertinente mais c'est
mélanger avec une espèce de fiscalité
punitive et moraliste sur le thème vous
avez une rente excessive et ça je
voudrais quand même rappeler que les
gilet jaune non seulement une voiture
mêlé gilet jaune ils ont aussi le
pavillon de banlieue que la société de
consommation leur a expliqué qu'il
fallait qu'ils achètent et qu'il
rembourse toute leur vie parce que c'est
la banque qui possède et eu ben là six
heures seule épargne est d'ailleurs la
nôtre à notre seule épargne canton les
salariés c'est cette espèce
d'augmentation donc comme il ya quelque
chose quand même qui est pas tout à fait
un film on se disait on taxe
l'immobilier parce qu'on veut taxer ce
qui est immobile et et pour me taxez moi
ce qui est mobile et que c'est aussi ça
le macrolane il ya toute la question de
la tour la transmission vous noterez que
le livre de la tête de liste l air
france a salué l'ami s'appelle demeure
est alors bon c'est celle de la
fiscalité voilà est-ce qu'ils nomment
louis mais c'est un livre qui réfléchit
à la transmission et il ya dans le dans
un certain projet macro niort ce qu'il
ya beaucoup de projets mac rognan mais
il y en a un où il ya une rupture de
transmission culturelle puisque ça n'est
pas le primat il ya une impossibilité de
la transmission des biens immobiliers
puisque il ya sont de ceux dont vous
parliez mais il ya eu dans les
propositions du grand débat le des taxes
sur les successions alors là il y en a
qui sont sortis dans tous les sens comme
si la succession était une injustice de
plus
or peut-être qu aux états unis ça marche
mais en france dans l'inconscient
collectif français
la maison l'appartement ça fait partie
de l'existence et la réussite d'une
existence mesure au fait qu'on arrive à
avoir son appartement ou sa maison c'est
peut-être complètement idiot mais c'est
comme ça
donc il me semble que c'est un peu à
contre-courant du pays etc
électoralement c'est bizarre parce que
comme le disait très bien géré on que
jaffray la partie de la droite qui
pourraient être tentés par emmanuel
macron est très attaché à l'immobilier
et n'est pas du tout quand elle lit les
les excellents numéro du figaro magazine
n'est pas du tout convaincu par ce
projet ce projet de d'augmentation des
taxes donc il me semble que c'est un des
points faibles
du programme dans marches pour essayer
de séduire les anciens électeurs de
françois fillon
merci beaucoup merci à tous les quatre
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
à vous de l'avoir suivi c'est terminé
pour ce soir mais point de vue revient
demain même heure même endroit avec
marie amélie lombard bonsoir à tous
[Musique]